Au large de Saint-Jean-de-Luz, il y a au fond redouté par les
pêcheurs sur les cartes marines, il porte le nom de Belharra.
Certains jours de tempête, il vaut mieux ne pas sortir en mer, car
lorsque la houle frappe le récif, l'endroit peut devenir un véritable piège.
Une vague se lève et fracasse tout sur son passage.
C'est un monstre d'écume qui dévore tous ceux qui tentent de le défier.
Les surfeurs de grosses vagues rêvent de se mesurer à elle,
mais peu sont ceux qui peuvent se vanter de l'avoir domptée.
La vague de Belharra est réputée pour être la plus haute vague du monde.
Elle fait la fierté de la côte basque et de ses surfeurs.
Chaque hiver, Benjamin Sanchis l'attend de pied ferme.
Benjamin est basque, il s'est fait connaître en février 2011 pour avoir surfer la
plus haute vague cette année là, elle mesurait 15 mètres et c'était à Belharra.
- L'enjeu déjà, c'est de n'est pas se noyer pour commencer.
C'est risqué parce que beaucoup d'eau.
La vague est très forte, très puissante.
Je suis tombé mal de fois là bas et
il faut respecter l'endroit, c'est sûr, comme partout ailleurs,.
Mais là bas, un petit peu plus...
Benjamin sillonne la planète.
Il est payé pour surfer les vagues les plus dangereuses au monde.
Ils s'exposent au danger pour le prestige d'une marque de
sport, pour la belle photo et pour gagner quelques prix.
15.000 $ à la clé pour sa vague de Belharra.
Le surf de gros est un monde à part.
À chaque périple, une véritable équipe de forces
entoure Benjamin avec caméraman, photographes et sauveteurs.
A la tête de ce team, il y a François Allix, c'est le boss.
Il donne les ordres et met en place une
incroyable logistique de sécurité pour minimiser les risques.
Cet hiver, François rassemble tout son monde
en terre basque pour guetter les tempêtes.
Depuis deux ans, il n'y a eu aucune grosse vague sur Belharra, mais
en ce mois de décembre, le temps se montre plus furieux que d'ordinaire.
D'après les calculs des météorologues, une forte houle semble
se diriger tout droit vers le récif de Belharra.
Mais le vent ne cesse de souffler et la mer est trop agitée.
Lorsque François Lites donne le signal.
- Pourquoi?
- Y a du vent grave?
- C'est normal?
- Je sais pas, mais bon, ça a cassé.
Aujourd'hui, ça va bien, car c'est déjà ça.
Ça ne va pas être très facile.
Benjamin est soucieux.
Il a l'habitude d'être déposé sur la vague géante tractée par la puissance
d'un jet ski, mais demain, il va devoir rivaliser avec les Américains.
Nathan Fletcher, vient d'arriver à Saint-Jean-de-Luz pour la première fois.
Le Californien veut aller chercher Belharra en ramant avec les bras.
- Moi, j'ai jamais surfé des vagues énormes en même temps.
Je ne prétend donc pas vraiment y arriver quoi que ce soit.
Je vais essayer. Je sais qu'il y a des
mecs qui sont là qui vont venir de Californie.
Les experts du gros surf de Belharra voir ces
mecs là chez soi, dans son jardin, c'est bien.
Je pense que Belharra, c'est vraiment une très, très grosse vacances.
C'est bien que ces mecs viennent justement parce
qu'ils vont voir de leurs propres yeux.
A quel point c'est une très, très grosse vague et
je ça très difficile de prendre à la rame.
Surfer sans l'aide d'un jet ski est une prise de risque supplémentaire.
Benjamin se rassure avec un nouvel élément de sécurité.
- Nouveauté aussi, ils ont inventé une combinaison
avec des capsules d'air comprimées dans le dos.
Voilà les capsules à comprimés mais là, ça sert à remonter, ça claque.
Le truc déclenche là et là, ça gonfle et une carapace comme une tortue géante.
- Ça, ça rassure ?
- Ça me rassure, si ça marche
à ça marche pas par exemple...
Si ça marche, c'est super rassurant, mais les mecs vont l'avoir ça.
Mais voilà, ça a marché, moyen.
Non ? Donc voila la planche qui rentre à peine dans mon appartement.
La taille explique la ça serait dommage.
Ce soir, Benjamin fait beaucoup d'efforts pour cacher son anxiété.
- J'ai fait des cookies cet après midi avec cette farce.
- J'ai deux bras et des jambes.
Le lendemain, sur la corniche de Saint-Jean-de-Luz,
une dizaine d'équipages de surfeurs scrutent l'horizon.
Quelques promeneurs curieux s'arrêtent eux aussi.
Avec le fort coefficient de la marée basse, la vague
devrait se lever sur le récif en fin de matinée.
L'équipe de Benjamin Sanchez sait que Belharra est
imprévisible et n'en fait qu'à sa tête.
- Ceci dit, ça va vraiment casser cette histoire ?
- Non, mais il y a eu une vraie vague qui a cassée quand même.
- Il ne se passe jamais rien et d'un seul coup.
Un jour, dans la Nuit des mousses géantes, qui cassent au large.
C'est tellement rare et les gens sont fiers de ça.
Ils adore, quand ça va casser.
Ils veulent venir la voir exceptionnelle quelque part.
C'est comme un rendez vous avec une femme, c'est un peu ça.
Comme un battement de cils, la belle semble faire signe à nos hommes.
- J'ai mes capsules...
Benjamín se fera en binôme avec un autre surfeur, Eric Rebière.
Belharra Lorsqu'elle frappe s'étire en animant ces dangereux champs
d'écume, Éric et Benjamin devront veiller l'un sur l'autre.
- C'est stressant parce que c'est presque eux
qui vont en prendre une dans la figure.
Nous partons à trois kilomètres au large, en pleine
mer, sur la zone du au fond de Bellara.
Comme c'est beau, la houle s'est formée et la
vague, ça fera plus de 12 mètres de haut.
Regard. Pour sa part.
Le bateau ne doit pas rester sur la zone d'impact.
Il faut se mettre à l'abri.
On risque rien parce que, en fait, il faut qu'il y ait minimum douve, pour que la casse là bas, en fait,
là ou les vacances, il y a entre 12 et 15 mètres de fond et là, on est nouille à 25 mètres.
Normalement, on.
Benjamin et Éric partent avec une équipe de sécurité
pour se faire déposer au plus près de Belharra.
C'est un véritable rodéo qui commence et il faut aller vite, contourner la vague et
se frayer un passage entre les surfeurs qui se font tracter par un jet.
Benjamin se place déterminé à réussir son exploit.
Avec Éric, ils se parlent et ils avancent ensemble.
Mais la force des bras ne suffira pas.
Le mur d'eau qui s'abat sur eux les frappe à plus de 60 km heure.
Pas mal baladé comme une grande machine à laver.
Mais il faut être bien calme et relaxé, ça s'arrête au bon moment.
Ce qui est bien, c'est qu'on va toucher beaucoup d'eau à respecter en
solo et de prendre la deuxième place selon la vague chasse nos hommes.
Belharra ne se laisse pas faire lorsque
Benjamin tente enfin de caresser la belle.
Il se fait rejeter pour l'équipe de sécurité en
ce qui reste toujours au plus près de Benjamin.
Éric, quant à lui, est resté d'interminables secondes sous l'eau.
Il a enclenché sa capsule de sauvetage, mais celle ci n'a pas fonctionné.
Il ne s'est pas gonflé.
Les lourdes planches ne font pas le poids face à la puissance de Belharra.
Le ciel s'assombrit et la vague se fait de plus en plus monstrueuse.
Un énorme.
Jusqu'à passer à travers les visages de nos surfeurs
sont fatigués et les bras n'en peuvent plus.
Natan Fletcher, le Californien, attend lui aussi en retrait.
Le petit groupe décide finalement de remonter le flanc de Belharra ensemble.
Benjamin se lance. Il passe une première vague
et attend Fletcher partir avec la belle.
Pour Benjamin, c'est maintenant ou jamais.
A son tour, Benjamin prouve qu'il est possible
de lutter à armes égales avec une géante.
La route est longue, dû me dire, mais c'est début début
chemin avec les dièses qui anthoine la fédératrices sur mes vêtements.
Ce n'est pas non plus un village gigantesque qui
doit donc aujourd'hui batailler avec tout le monde.
Avec des Dgesco. Je préfère passer la journée, même si on va faire des vagues.
On ne va pas prendre des vagues incroyables à essayer de
ramer quelque chose de nouveau et passer à l'étape supérieure.
On apprend, c'est mi chemin initiatique à l'entrée de la route.
Alors, comme la houle, il poursuit sa route vers le sud.
Benjamin n'attend pas.
Le soir même, il se précipite pour ne pas rater un deuxième rendez vous.
Le lendemain, il sera au Portugal, au
large d'une autre corniche, celle de Masaru.
Ce jour là, il s'offre sa plus belle rencontre de l'hiver.
Une vague de seize mètres de haut.
Surfer, là encore à la force des bras.